Finding that I need to go to a conventional, to a convention, and concerned about clean food sources.
So, I may fast. How do you fast when some of the supplements are required to be taken with food?
So, first of all, should a cancer patient fast?
Well, a cancer patient really shouldn't fast more than 24 hours, because if you do more than a 24 hour fast,
you're going to increase IGF1 levels, which are growth hormones, and you can make things worse.
So, I wouldn't just fast if you're going to a convention.
You can source food in some way by bringing in some food with you somehow, so you have something to consume.
If you're going to be at just a convention for a day, is that what you're, what I'm understanding, then you're not going to eat during that day that you're at that convention.
Yeah, you could make a smoothie or something to bring with you, that you could take your supplements with your smoothie.
Maybe that would be helpful.
The only supplement that you really absolutely need to take with food is the digestive enzyme, a clear digest or HCl's Imer, digestime plus or whatever you're taking.
And if you're not eating, then you don't take that, so you take that with a meal to help you digest that food.
But if you're taking other things with food because you notice that it's helpful to take it with food, then that's some that you're going to have to come up with something to eat.
So you just mentioned that it's three days long.
There's no way you could pass for three days. That could be harmful for you.
So you're going to have to find some source of food, do your best that you possibly can.
I know if you're at a convention where there's not a lot of sources around and things, you're just going to have to do.
You just have to make the best choices as well.
Maybe you just get something with a chicken breast or something like that. You just make the best choices you could do.